No one here
is not a dreamer.
Not in a world
like this,
where you can
have it all.
We live with miracles
at our fingertips.
We got robots taking
out the trash.
We fly to the stars.
And that's
what I want
for you
and your families.
That's the dream
you all deserve.
Soon you folks
will be saying,
"Wow!"
I love living
on the moon.
♫ Fly me to the moon ♫
Remember we're
not just selling.
We're changing lives.
Congratulations!
On your new home
in the stars.
I’ve been thinking about
moving up there.
The moon might
be nice.
What about all
them aliens?
Well,
there's no
such thing.
♫ Jupiter and Mars ♫
What is this?
What's going on?
Did we do
something wrong?
♫ Fly me to the moon ♫
I'm going to
tell him soon.
What do you
think I am?
I know what you are.
You're going to
rip him away
from everything
decent.
Everyone else plays
fast and loose.
Why can't we?
What?
♫ Jupiter and Mars
In other words... ♫
The music can't stop.
Because we get
to dream
on a better
tomorrow.
♫ ...hold my hand... ♫
I left my whole
life for this.
I want the truth.
♫...in other words... ♫
What are we
selling here?
♫...in other words... ♫
I can't fix
our problems.
♫...in other words... ♫
We'll find a way.
You and me.
There are some things
you should know
about Jack.
And your brighter
tomorrow
doesn't start when you
land on the moon.
It starts today!
♫ To the moon ♫